let me let me let me do this we'll give
a shout out uh to this famous video that
i've been dying to to talk to you about
bill maher
you were on you on real time with bill
maher what was it like 2017 or 20 no no
no it was actually 2019 20 which is even
more remarkable how recent
so you were on uh with bill maher and
you you mentioned that there are uh
tampons in the men's restrooms at
universities
and bill the panel and the audience i
said men menstruate is a left-wing lie
right okay and then they all started
laughing and bill maher goes what
what are you doing
and you were like it's in the news look
it up and they were like no and you were
like they have tampons in the men's room
and bill goes it's for their girlfriends
remarkable the arrogance and ignorance
at the same time
instead of just being like
i'm go i gotta call here's what i'd say
if you said something to me that i
thought was wrong i'd pull it up and if
we were on a show like that i would be
like
are you serious with this is this true
can we get someone to check that and
guess what they would have done they had
to come back and be like he's right
right correct
well
i i it was a great moment because the
entire panel
bill maher and the entire audience
laughed at me
and uh just for the record i actually
enjoy that i'm not a masochist
but
when i know i'm right and you have a
whole bunch of people laughing at you
it is so revealing as to how easily
people are brainwashed
that that's the reason that i liked it
that that audience didn't hear it from
the new york times so it didn't happen
that that
they as i say on my radio show almost
every day
they don't know that is the left they
don't know what we know well so uh i
pulled up the article because we
actually did a segment on it it's an old
article this is an article from the
daily beast which is fake news by the
way newsguard says they're fake news um
published september 21st 2016 which is
titled yes men can have periods and we
need to talk about them so
2016 you go on bill maher's show three
years right later years
so that's why i say it's it's left and
right in this country is do you read the
news or are you just an arrogant also it
shows you this is a very important
lesson the speed with which the left can
have people say
wet is dry
this is this that was october
uh or or november of 2019
and within a year and a half if you said
men do not menstruate you are considered
a hater
that is how fast the left changes
half this country's views on a equals b
equals c this is the issue i i i
this is the issue i have with bill maher
right i do appreciate that he's called
out woke nonsense that he believes in
free speech but the man doesn't do
research
i i i don't know is he retired you know
is is this you know i i i say retired in
the sense that he's phoning it in he
shows up he says give me the cue cards
he sits down and he says what he's gonna
buy i didn't read that and it's like
bill this story is three and a half
years old if you don't know about this
that's your fault not mine how could a
guy have one of the he has a million
viewers per per night when he does a
show per night you know per show which
is weekly and this guy didn't bother
to read the news three and a half years
ago i mean this story has been extremely
prominent it's not it's not this one
article i've pulled up the issue
surrounding this has been going on for
quite some time the issues surrounding
racial segregation has been happening
over and over and over again you would
have to actively ignore the news to not
know these things
yeah i just want to say uh that
it's so rare to have a liberal call out
the left
that i i want i want to salute him
as you pointed out yourself he he it
does call out wokeness uh but you you
you would think he would have known it
that is correct i think it's an example
of kind of the old media model of like
let's have an interview and dan be the
consequences versus the new model of
let's have access to the internet and
look it up and fact check in real time
like rogan never would have had a hit
show if he didn't have someone looking
up the facts he would have just been
wrong a bunch and looked like an idiot
well i think the biggest thing is
admitting that you're wrong and i think
that's the biggest difference between
individuals online and there are a lot
of individuals predominantly who are
promoted by big tech social media that
never admit that they are wrong bill
maher just a couple weeks ago was
talking about how the economy is doing
great we're in a recovery everything's
fine the the right wingers are are being
sensationalistic when it comes to the
dire economic numbers and here we are
sitting with the calamity that that
we're facing uh that is absolutely
unavoidable right now is he going to to
talk about his mistakes probably not and
and you know i'll give you my thoughts
on this we mentioned this the other day
we had a jamie killstein and he's a he's
a
liberal comedian i guess but he was
canceled and you know came after him so
he's like formerly woke and we were
talking about the red flag laws
and i said red flag laws it's stop and
frisk on steroids so i'm at occupy wall
street jamie's at occupy wall street
luke's down there and across the
spectrum we're like stop and frisk is a
bad thing what they were doing you're
familiar with stopping firsthand of
course so it turns out according to a
few whistleblowers that the mayor
actually ordered the police or i should
say the police were ordered to
specifically target racial minorities
and the justification was well that's
the demographic committing the crime and
the response on the left was like if
it's the neighborhood perhaps but to
come out blanket just be like no it was
the racial group so we were like
these terry stops are a violation of
your of your fourth amendment rights
regardless i'm not a fan red flag laws
are the same thing but now they can go
into your house how was it that the left
and liberals were like stop and frisk is
wrong and morally repugnant but red flag
laws it's even worse but we should have
that there's no logical consistency to
what they're arguing for
so you know we're talking with jamie and
his attitude is like i didn't think
about it that way but you're right
stop and frisk was a bad thing why would
the left be a championing for something
worse than it which is the same thing
the left doesn't think
about right and wrong it thinks about
it
morality separates this is this is my
field as it were
the moral
outlook on life is
what is right what is wrong what is good
what is bad
the left since lenin really since marx
never asked that
it doesn't divide the world between good
and bad it divides the world between
rich and poor
black and white
strong and weak male and female
imperialist versus victim
that does not those are its divisions
not good and bad
i knew i learned this at columbia when i
was told by every single professor i had
it is not possible to be a black racist
it is not possible when was that what oh
this 1970s wow
so
a lot of this stuff is not new it's
worse than ever it's more absurd than
ever but it's not new that is a very
important statement a black cannot be a
racist it means moral criteria do not
apply
where there's a racial criterion
race trumps morality economics trump
morality power trumps morality morality
is not a left-wing consideration and and
and those of us who think in normal
terms wait there's right and wrong a
black could be a racist the white could
be a racist the black could be beautiful
or white could be beautiful no that is
none left thinking right i don't know if
you
some people say left some people say
people who are indoctrinated and don't
critically think there was an incredible
video that that was highlighted that i
that i played on on one of my members
areas uh today specifically highlighting
a young man at an abortion rally
specifically women who are arguing for
abortion for women's reproductive rights
and he asked him my body my choice all
of them said absolutely a hundred
percent and then he asked him where did
you stand on the mandates just a few
months ago and all of them oh yeah with
the vaccine mandates specifically and
all of them had this moment of uh but
that's different
that's what they said yeah that's that's
different one woman the last one was
funny she goes i'm not talking about
that exactly
but the principles the morals there you
know they're inconsistent they're
they're absolutely illogical that people
are not critically thinking they're
being swayed by emotional mind control
that's telling them what they should be
believing and pushing for fitting in
tribe cult
most of these default liberal types just
want to fit in so whatever the machine
tells them they say okay
then you have the left which has seized
the reins of the machine and they're
just thrown out edict so is communism
the easiest thing to fit into like
politically geopolitically um
as opposed to like because it's not easy
to be an american that's constantly
freaking out about freedom and like
always thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you